being together almost 30 years now and
not going a day without speaking to now
going on four months is a lot mine and
Jews lives you know it's fairly
consistent after 25 years of being
married I don't think there's a single
letter that goes by that she does not
say how much she misses my dad Savannah
Chrisley getting candid on her unlocked
podcast about parents Todd and Julie
overall I mean it's not glamorous you
don't lie you don't cheat you don't
steal they're both in federal prison the
Christie knows best are offering new
details about Mom and Dad's life Behind
Bars it's definitely harder on her I
think than it is my dad I think she's
trying to Shield us from a lot of things
because that's my mom that's who she is
but the biggest Revelation Todd and
Julie prohibited from speaking to each
other and they haven't talked since
surrendering to prison in January yeah
four months in almost and being together
almost 30 years now and not going a day
without speaking to now going on four
months is a lot people don't talk about
that and that's the tough part is our
system's already breaking people you're
just
prohibiting communication between two
people
who have been married for almost 30
years like what are you doing to
families if Todd and Julie could share a
message with the world what do you think
they'd want them to know I think they'd
want folks to know that they are the
same people they've always been and
they're going to fight to get their name
cleared because God didn't bring us this
far to drop us off following the
couple's convictions for bank fraud and
tax evasion they're serving a combined
19-year sentence far from their
Nashville Mansions Todd's facility is in
Florida meanwhile Julie's 655 miles away
in Kentucky so every weekend at someone
and that's the hard part of figuring out
like all right who am I going to go see
yeah the commute is a big part of the
Chrisley family's New Normal with Dad
it's a seven hour drive so I will
normally pick Chloe up from school on
Fridays start driving we'll get there at
about like midnight and then we're at
Dad's Facility by 8 A.M to visit him
from 8 to 3 do the same thing Sunday and
then drive home and then we start the
week over again I love my children more
than I've ever loved anything in life we
all share a same common Bond of faith
and we're going to always be there for
each other as for Julie she's giving
Savannah letters that Chronicle her time
in prison with Mom I'll leave at like 5
a.m drive to Kentucky see her then drive
home
and just her letters I mean it was tough
to see the accounts of her day and just
things that she's scared of or nervous
about or just all the thoughts that go
through her mind and not having my dad
there with her that's the biggest thing
any family who faces a loved one going
to prison
um it's a very difficult challenge but
they're strong they're faithful and I
think they'll continue in that Way
Forward I've never seen two people my
parents be so steadfast in their faith
in the end the truth will prevail may
get harder before it gets easier but we
have faith
friends